hallo herzlich willkommen ihr meine
trocken welt heute verrate ich euch ein
leckeres brot und zwar das walken brot
das brot eignet sich hervorragend zum
grillen oder als beilage von salat und
was ihr dazu benötigt das sage ich jetzt
für den hefeteig benötigt ihr 600 gramm
mehl 300 gramm lauwarmes wasser einen
würfel hefe einen halben teelöffel
zucker zwei teelöffel salz und 50 gramm
zuerst müsst ihr jetzt ein hefeteig
erstellen dazu geht jetzt eure zutaten
die in euren küchenmaschine oder italien
per hand ich mache es heute in einem
tagungsband einfach viel schneller geht
und ich weniger arbeit habe dazu nehme
ich einfach den deckel ab gibt alle
zutaten 3
bevor es dazu kommt verrät ihr als die
anderen zutaten damit die regel besser
arbeiten kann
dann schalte ich hier auf zwei minuten
verschließt die maschine und stücke auf
die knete taste
und jetzt gebe ich noch kurz dazu
und wenn er zeigt angekettet ist holt er
ihn aus asche geht etwas unterstützung
und da kommt der tag dann rein und
wieder abgedeckt an einem waren orte in
totale schon gegeben
während total geht's aufgeht können die
zwischenzeit einmal die kräuterbutter
herstellen und die zutaten dazu ständig
euch kurz bürgern für die kräuterbutter
braucht ihr 120 g weiche butter dann ein
paar gewürze also saß pfeffer hier habe
ich drei zehen knoblauch etwas oregano
und chili und ich gebe gern noch ein
paar frische kräuter mit dazu und zwar
petersilie pfefferminze und basilikum
die frischen kräuter und die
knoblauchzehen müssen jetzt lacht und
dann mit der butter vermischt werden
ich werde das jetzt ganz schnell in
einer küchenmaschine machen er keine
küchenmaschine hass der presse die
knoblauchzehen durch eine
knoblauchpresse oder schneidet alles per
hand und vermischtes dann alles in
tempelhof zuerst gibt dir jetzt die
knoblauchzehen und die kräuter in den
mix topf und das ganze wird jetzt bei
stufe 8 in acht sekunden klein
gehäckselt
und dann kommt da noch die butter mit
dazu und die restlichen gewürze und das
wird jetzt in 25 sekunden auf stufe
sechs verrührt
wenn der himmel tag dann gegangen ist
und die füllung vorbereitet ist müsst
ihr es das brot noch formen und wie das
geht zeigt nicht hier
dazu legt ihr eure jene teig gibt etwas
mehr läuft die arbeitsfläche dann kommt
da der teig drauf
und den teig rollt jetzt rechteckig aus
und auf den teig kommt jetzt die butter
wasser
und jetzt kommt der teil wie das rot
front und zwar schneidet ihr etwa 5 cm
breiter streifen
und ich halte es immer noch mal und
diese streifen die legte jetzt so
zusammen wie eine ziehharmonika einfach
so zusammenfalten
minute an alle haben durch die reform
ihr könnt auch eine springform nehmen
oder ihn so wie ich eine kleine
glaskasten vorn
und dann legt dieter ganz willkürlich
eure gefalteten brot teile reihen
entweder könnte sich in stellen so dass
die zeit kannte hier oben zu sehen ist
oder er legt sie suchen hin
und das könnte jetzt ganz willkürlich
machen als er wild durcheinander
vor dem backen muss das boot ist noch
einmal gehen ich lasse es etwa 20
minuten nochmal an dem warmen ort stehen
und danach wenn es bei 200 grad etwa 30
bis 35 minuten gebacken
dass beide gewohnt sieht dann so aus
danach stützt jetzt auch reform wenn ihr
springform habt könnt ihr natürlich ganz
einfach den rand und das brot es noch
nicht geschnitten werden man kann sich
einfach hier
die stückchen abreißen ich hoffe das
rezept im weltall
ich persönlich finde ganz super weil es
einfach schnell geht ich brauche dich
wieder zutaten mit dazu und außerdem
geht es auch ganz einfach dann wünsche
ich euch viel spaß beim nachbacken und
darüber dass er das nächste mal wieder
einschalten meine tage hält